I was just watching some stuff last
night about it I mean it is it is a it
is powerful
Chadwicks of his audience I mean she's
so fantastic and from what I've heard
you've seen the film he really knocks it
out of the park black panther hits
theaters as et catches up with Captain
America himself Chris Evans the two
faced off in civil war but recently came
together off screen to celebrate 10
years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I mean truly everywhere you looked there
was another person from another iconic
film that has probably meant something
to you over the course of your acting
career so it's a cap we'll pick up some
new weaponry courtesy of Wakanda and
Avengers infinity war this may but first
he's taken Broadway as a New York City
police officer in lobby hero opening
March 26 I spent some time with some
cops and I've done a bunch of you know
we have a dialect coach because I have
to do a New York accent so listening to
a lot of their speech patterns and we've
had some cops come into our rehearsal
space and ask them some questions and
you know trying to get my best cop
stance
[Music]